Like everything, humans are made up of atoms.
But what’s interesting, is how we behave
so very similar to them.
Atoms share electron pairs with other atoms
in order to become stable and form covalent
bonds.
Human relationships are just like that of
covalent bonds and reflect the same process
of give-and-take.
Relationships develop out of some divine-like
push and pull.
When we allow it, we are magnetized towards
other people that are compatible with our
polarity.
Two people become into one mutual life when
a stable bond is formed.
These bonds are formed all through life, attempting
to balance out all of our unstable forces
in the process.
In theory, this is a beautiful system that
guarantees balanced and receptive relationships
throughout life.
But then why does it seem like there are so
many challenges associated with human social-life?
Why is true friendship and partnership so
hard to find?
This challenge rises out of our insecurities
and fears.
Our fear of being our self and having others
dislike it.
But when we submit to this fear and hide behind
its wall, we inadvertently prevent our electron
pairs from being fully revealed to the world.
Our whole self hides behind the wall and the
polarized system of push and pull becomes
broken.
It is like someone holding their hand in front
of a camera lens.
No one can see the subject.
No one can enjoy the subject.
For successful social relationships to occur,
your whole image must be visible.
By removing your hand from the lens, you reveal
your true self to the world and allow others
to do the same.
If you want people to truly care for you and
allow you to care for them, you must be willing
to present your full self without fear.
If, instead, you hide behind fear’s wall,
you will never find the stability and connection
we all so desire in life.
Instead of forming balance like atoms, you
will only form temporariness and insecurity.
Like a cigarette, your life will be smoked
away by those you encounter in life.
Your ashes will be flicked into the wind until
nothing remains.
You will treat others the same way and feel
slight and temporary pleasure from your relationships,
but the sensations will soon dissipate and
you will soon be left with nothing.
Not everyone is going to match with your polarity
in life.
Accept this and do not bother trying to force
relationships with those who do not.
You must, instead, search only for those who
DO match with your truest self.
Like when you are scanning the radio and come
across a station with poor reception, you
must not stay and listen to the static of
meaningless social relationships.
You must keep scanning until you find value
and clarity.